you know no matter what you may think of
Harvard University one thing you can't
dispute is how important the institution
used to be in previous generations it
was a Harvard faculty member who first
popularized the small poox vaccine in
the United States Harvard researchers
developed some of the world's first
computers a Harvard scientist named
James Watson famously modeled the DNA
double helix Harvard was an institution
that made real world discoveries that
changed the lives of millions of people
and when you heard from Harvard
professors and administrators uh you you
took them seriously back in those days
they weren't cynical political actors
they were competent and serious that was
the whole point of Harvard with that
history mind it was both depressing and
a little bit surreal surreal to watch
this recent video message from Harvard's
new president who's a political
scientist named Claudine gay and in case
you missed it gay took over as Harvard's
president this year to much fanfare for
the simple reason that she is now the
first black president of the University
it was her skin color and her gender
that were the primary
qualifications and nobody really denies
that it's how Harvard admits students
these days and it's how Harvard selects
faculty members and administrators as
well in the video claudin gay responds
to Nationwide outrage that many Harvard
students have just decided to publicly
support Hamas in the wake of its terror
attack on Israel which killed more than
a thousand people in the aftermath of
that attack nearly three dozen student
groups at Harvard signed onto a
statement saying that Israel was quote
fully responsible for the massacre of
its own people and this was a big
problem for Harvard as you might imagine
because it's completely and utterly
Psychopathic and naturally a lot of
people were calling for Harvard to take
action in response to what these
students were saying so um after hearing
all of that here's how Claudine gay the
new president of Harvard responded watch
this is a moment of intense pain and
grief for a great many people in our
community and around the world I feel
that pain and grief
myself as members of university
community we have a
choice we can fan the Flames of division
and hatred that are roiling the
world or we can try to be a force for
something different and
better people have asked me where we
stand so let me be
clear our University rejects terrorism
that includes the barbaric atrocities
perpetrated by Hamas
our University rejects hate hate of Jews
hate of Muslims hate of any group of
people based on their faith their
national origin or any aspect of their
identity our University rejects the
harassment or intimidation of
individuals based on their
beliefs and our University Embraces a
commitment to free
expression that commitment extends even
to views that many of us find
objectionable even
outrageous you know things are going
well when you have to put out a
statement saying that you reject
terrorism to be clear this University
rejects
terrorism cannibalism drowning puppies
we're against all of it to be
clear now first of all this this needs
to be said Claudine gay sounds
indistinguishable there from a random
fourth grade teacher in that clip I mean
if you watch that footage without any
context you'd have to ask yourself uh
yeah ask yourself this could you tell
that that was the president of Harvard I
mean if you still thought that Harvard
was a place for smart people would you
be able to tell that that was the
president of Harvard probably not and to
prove that point Helen Andrews at the
American conservative went back and
looked at speeches from the president of
Harvard from 50 years ago and Andrews
found that Harvard presidents uh maybe
not surprisingly used to sound a lot
different from claudi and gay you could
tell that they were the presidents of
the leading University in the country
just by listening to them now you'd have
no idea claudian gay sounds like a a
random middle manager somewhere or like
a substitute teacher at some Middle
School she sounds like she should be
running the HR department at some
moderately sized company there's nothing
special about what she's saying it's not
intelligent or insightful it's not
especially eloquent or wise and in so
far as claudian gay said anything at all
here's the Crux of it she said quote our
University Embraces a commission to uh
free expression that commitment extends
even to views that many of us find
objectionable even
outrageous now if you take that at face
value it's a reasonable sentiment speech
on college campuses shouldn't be
suppressed or punished even if it's
gratuitously wrong that's understandable
enough I mostly agree with it it's why
we have universities allegedly one of
the reasons I mean the the the free
exchange of ideas is supposed to be a
big part of the program as long as
you're not threatening anybody with
imminent violence then you should be
allowed to say what you think and
universities in this Ideal World would
be places where young people can
experiment with ideas where they can
adopt positions that are perhaps radical
and then try to defend those positions
intellectually in open debate that's one
of the ways that you can find out that
your ideas are wrong is by having them
challenged and trying to defend them and
if you're never in a position where you
have to defend your ideas then you may
never discover that you are horrifically
wrong about everything that you
think so that's how I ities should work
maybe it's how they once did work it
would be nice if they still work that
way but they don't anymore and that's
the point so the problem and it's a very
big problem is that Claudine gay clearly
does not agree with her own statement
like so many leftists she's pretending
to embrace some kind of universal
principle of open expression even though
she's she's more than willing to reneg
on those principles when it's convenient
for her to do so she Embraces free
expression if the expression excuses
terrorism but she certainly doesn't
Embrace speech that contradicts her
preferred narratives about say gender
ideology or
BLM and we don't have to guess about
that by the way consider that it was
just a year ago that Harvard told
students that if they quote misgender a
fellow student meaning if they use the
appropriate pronouns to describe a
student's gender if they use
grammatically correct language then they
are potentially guilty of abuse every
undergraduate at Harvard was told that
if they use the wrong quote unquote
wrong pronouns for fellow student or if
they do anything to quote lower a
person's
self-worth than they're subject to
disciplinary proceedings this is all
according to a reporting from the
Washington Free Beacon but claudian gay
never issued any impassion video message
in defense of Harvard students rights to
refer to one another by their actual
biological sex she never affirmed the
right of Harvard students to express
their belief in things like reality and
biology instead she sat idly by a
approvingly nodding her head as students
were told that they'll suffer severe
consequences unless they affirm the
delusions of their mentally ill
classmates the G20 is an international
forum for governments and Central Bank
Governors it was established in response
to the financial crisis of the late uh
1990s with the aim of promoting
International Financial stability well
last month the G20 announced a plan to
impose digital currencies and digital
IDs on their respective populations
Central Bank digital currency has
essentially allowed the government to
track every purchase you make even if
you don't follow International economic
policies that closely uh you should be
concerned and you should consider
diversifying at least some of your
assets into physical gold with the help
of Birch gold group call Birch gold
today to preserve your savings in a tax
sheltered retirement account if you have
an IRA of 401k from a previous employer
that's just Gathering dust call Birch
gold and they will help you convert it
into an IRA in Gold you're not going to
pay a penny out of pocket they will
simply convert that 401k that's just
sitting there at a bank somewhere into
physical gold which can't be tampered
with text Walsh to 98 9898 and Birch
gold will send you a free info kit on
gold if digital currency becomes a
reality you will be glad you have
something physical to fall back on text
Walsh to 98 9898 and claim your free
info kit on gold today there are many
other examples of Claud and Gay's
apparent lack of commitment to freedom
of speech to give just one more example
it was just a few years ago that
Claudine gay oversaw the destruction of
a black Harvard Professor named Roland
frier frier ruffled a lot of feathers at
Harvard because of his heterodox uh
findings on race and policing
specifically frier found that there's no
statistical evidence that Police use
disproportionate lethal Force against
black suspects even though this is
everything we've been told by BLM and
the race Hustlers what he found is that
it's all bunk it's not true Fri also
found that black students who perform
well in school are often shunned by
their black peers for being quote two
whites now how did clauden gay respond
to this well she tried to burn the
heretic of course here's the backstory
from frier fired a uh a staff assistant
who then accused him of sexual
misconduct and Harvard's own
investigators found that the staff
assistants claims were mostly bogus and
they recommended that frier received
some HR training and that's it but
Claudine gay who saw frier as an
existential threat because of his his
views on things decided to overrule that
recommendation from Harvard Zone
investigators she wanted frier fired
there's a short documentary on YouTube
about this case here's a a relevant
piece of it watch
one thing the Harvard investigator found
was that Roland Fri never never sexually
propositioned or made sexual advances on
a single woman in his office not
once uh well so that's
it Josh that is it Harvard's own
investigators determined that Roland's
punishment should be some training some
workplace sensitivity training okay I
feel like you're about to tell me
something a little bit
more he didn't just get
[Music]
training they passed the recommendation
to a small Committee of high-ranking
Administrators I was only able to figure
out the identity of two members of that
committee okay one of them is Claud in
gay the other one is Larry Bobo
yeah like champagne Silver Spoon
liberals right right people whose
careers and reputations were directly
threatened by Roland's
work those are the people that get to
determine Roland's
punishment what happens
next Larry Bobo came in and he read out
the punishment it started with the lab
is going to be permanently closed and I
was like
what and then it goes on to all of the
projects that you've been working on
have been halted
so this is free speech on uh the Harvard
campus Claudine gay and one of her
colleagues correctly identified Friar's
research as completely contradictory to
their own research frier was saying that
the police aren't racist and claudian
gay was saying that we live in a white
supremacist Terror State and lo and
behold gay has a chance to adjudicate a
complaint against frier so she decides
to throw the book at him um in
contradiction to what Harvard's
investigators had recommended based on
their own findings after actually doing
the investigation in fact she petitions
Harvard president to revoke prior
Friar's tenure so he'd never be allowed
to step foot on Harvard's campus ever
again um this kind of retaliation this
hostility towards disfavored speech is
the norm at Harvard it has been the norm
for a very long time according to the
foundation for individual rights and
expression or fire Harvard has a quote
dismal record of responding to
deplatforming attempts attempts to
sanction students student groups
Scholars and speakers for speech
protected under First Amendment
standards of nine attempts in total over
the past 5 years seven resulted in
sanction Fri also declared that Harvard
had received its quote worst score ever
in Fire's college free speech rankings
its worst score fire specifically notes
that quote from 2019 to this year
Harvard sanctioned four Scholars three
of whom it terminated in 2020 Harvard
revoked conservative student activist
Kyle Cash's acceptance over comments he
made on social media as a 16-year-old
for which he had since apologized in
2022 Harvard disinvited feminist
philosopher Devin Buckley from an
English Department colloquium uh on
campus over her views on gender and
trans issues fires report goes on to
explain that according to survey results
many Harvard students self-censor their
political views they're also subject to
uh to hostility if they espouse pro-life
views on campus Etc so it's everything
you'd expect don't you dare suggest that
the police aren't hunting down black men
and uh and murdering them in Cold Blood
that crosses a line that's because at
Harvard and many other so-called Elite
universities the only sort of speech
they have a problem with is true speech
the war on free speech on campus is a
war on Truth Harvard and claudian gay
simply cannot tolerate the truth which
is much worse than simply not tolerating
opposing
ideas what makes the situation on
American campuses so dire is not just
that speech is suppressed but it is
specifically the type of speech they
suppress true
speech if you're going to suppress any
speech and I'm not saying you should but
if you do it should be false speech
untrue speech delusional and crazy and
morally deranged speech but Harvard
along with many other college campuses
most college campuses goes the other way
untrue speech is welcomed true speech is
not now I'm happy to be wrong about all
this I'd love nothing more than it' be
proven incorrect on this point as it
pertains to Harvard
I've already announced that I'd love to
come to Harvard and and give a talk so
that Harvard can really have a chance to
prove its Free Speech
bonafides this is the generous offer I
made on Twitter the other day and and I
mean it what better way for Claudine gay
and Harvard leadership to demonstrate
their support for diverse viewpoints
than to host somebody like me on their
campus and I'd be happy to I'd be happy
to show up I'll clear my schedule I'm
sure many of my colleagues would as well
would would Ben Shapiro be welcomed at
Harvard right now to give the
alternative Viewpoint to those pramas
student
groups maybe we could do a whole
dailywire
Symposium right on campus just a
suggestion if Harvard and Claud and gay
are serious about their commitment to
freedom of speech no matter how odious
they think that speech may be then this
should be a
no-brainer I haven't heard back from
Harvard since uh my tweet a few days ago
announcing my interest in speaking on
campus so right now I'll ask student
groups directly if you'd like to host me
on campus just say so I'm ready and
willing to show up and unlike claudi and
gay my commitment to free speech and
debate isn't conditional or
opportunistic you invite me I show up
it's that simple and if Harvard students
and faculty can defeat me in open debate
then uh I'll have no problem with that
that's the way it goes I'm happy with
the whole world seeing whatever
transpires I didn't graduate from
Harvard or any college like it or any
college at all and yet despite all of
that I will show up I am nothing more
than a high school graduate who is is
willing to openly debate ivv league
students and faculty live on
camera how could they do anything but
jump at that
opportunity I'm not
afraid so I have this simple question
for claudi and gay and all the
administrators and student leaders at
Harvard what exactly are you afraid of
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there